as but
the heart-wrenching goodbyes as Victor
maruska is carried away at 87 he and his
wife Lydia are about to embark on their
new life as displaced persons leaving
behind the memories of a lifetime and
their daughter Marina in eastern Ukraine
she fears that this is the last time she
will see her parents
it was a very difficult decision I
understand that this might be the last
time I'll see her again it's really hard
I hope they'll be hosted by someone at
their age I can't give them proper care
here
they will be taken to a nursing home in
the west of the country their home time
of promoters wants home to about 150
000 has been caught between the two
sides since 2014. the russian-backed
separatists briefly took it over before
Ukraine regained control in 2015. now
chromatosk has become a Garrison town
where Ukrainian troops are trying to
hold the Russian Advance underground but
is proving difficult as Russian troops
get closer to cities like Crematory and
bakmut prompting Ukraine's president
volodimir zelensky to order the force
relocation of civil Millions from the
Donetsk region an estimated two to three
hundred thousand are believed to still
be living there zelenski wants them to
leave before autumn water electricity
and gas already scarce says Maria zoza
who managed to reach the nearest train
station some 50 kilometers away from
crematores
but the danger to life is getting bigger
every day we were told that there won't
be any heating now we have water for a
few hours on a good day sometimes we
don't for two or three days we could
cope but we have to leave for the sake
of our children
this is a war of attrition on the ground
and long-range missiles from the sky
it started in the name of liberating and
protecting Russian speakers such as
Valentina abramanovska who Moscow said
were facing genocide by authorities in
Kiev the only momentum Valentina is
carrying an old photograph of her mother
and sister taken nearly 50 years ago
she survived the German occupation of
Ukraine during the second world war she
says the Russian bombardments with
modern Weaponry are far worse
everything is shaking inside me I can't
calm down I was all alone all day
yesterday and today I was going crazy
there are beasts jackals God forgive me
for what I'm saying how's it possible
the journey towards Western Ukraine will
take several days no one here knows when
they will be back but as the air Sirens
goes off once again many know leaving
their Hometown was the best option